hi I'm Finn wolfhard and I'm milli Bobby
Brown and I'm Noah Schnapp and today we
will be doing the autocomplete interview
for Wired all right guys look are you
cheating and that the other board here
we go so first up we have yeah there it
is dance dance well what were you yes
she likes the Millie wrong what were you
just doing three minutes it was dancing
that's very nice yep does many movie
Groundhog I do
yes she does his name is Charlie turn
around does Millie what we brown have a
sister I have two sisters I have Paige
and Ava does many brown support me
before I am an avid Liverpool supporter
all right there we go
what's fennel of Hearts favorite song
kelp City boy by Calpurnia my own song
is my favorite song oh the Rolling
Stones Liz oh yeah probably waiting on a
friend by the Rolling Stones Liz oh yeah
wisdom whistle was out boys what is the
wolf arts band called Calpurnia Pyrenean
that's an easy one what is not really
what's Finn wolf hards dog's name
her name was Rosie she is dead however
thanks for bringing up great memories
and what what school does fit a wolf our
guide you good question
what guitar that's right oh I have a few
I have a Fender Mustang a Fender Jaguar
a Rickenbacker love 360 yeah those are
really good merits I'm just gonna stop
talking alrighty next up says what I
wish know what know what snap what know
it snap what I wish first we have what
the movies has notion have been in oh
I've been in there like I played Charlie
Brown in the peanuts movie and I played
I forget his name his name was Roger and
I'm moving closer
spies and then I did a bunch of other
like indie films and stuff but those
like the biggest ones I guess why does
Noah schnaps robot roblox I love robots
it's this game and have one oh my god
you're say oh I always play with
Millie's little sister do you have one
uh yeah it's um okay I don't really know
I think like no it cool awesome I made
it when I was like five okay what apps
doesn't know where she at huh
yeah there's a lot of apps right we have
a few I have a good I have a bunch of
good I mean calculators a nap
oh I felt like takes pictures and
translates oh I have a fake call app so
I can like type in someone's name and
then they can call me pretty excited
president absolutely you know should we
do this well you know we just should do
anyone okay I have a bunch of good apps
what blankies oh sorry that's not my
name
what color our eyes does Noah schnap
have hazel hazel kind of they're green
oh my gran what does Noah schnap think
of you yes oh and honestly I think
you're a very beautiful person I think
we should go out sometime the hole all
right
yeah next okay Oh today today only 15
years old
what is with every browser DX I'm I'm on
the cusp of Aquarius and Pisces so I
relate more to Pisces though I mean
we're both yeah okay what happened to
Melanie brownie oh my god of course III
broke my knee in half yeah slip what is
many when we Browns favorite color
guys purples I was I was gonna mean
really wrong and say you hated essence
what and what what are you to say no
fine clothes
ah then what it what are you am I having
a head injury because I don't know if
this is English or not what are you are
you like in relationship to Malaysian Oh
what are you like what are you these
young comes with water so I I'm okay
well then I'm just then I'm just mean
what is fin wolfhard nationality I'm
Canadian is that nationality yeah yes
yes what instrument does fin wolfhard
play I play piano guitar guitar and bass
and drums and a harmonica and you play a
beautiful one and I have a beautiful
that I mean this is a village strip look
at that what does Finn wolfhard love me
sick baby yeah
never say that Anna Noah schnap and
million Bobby Brown oh yeah the cast of
stranger to stranger tanks what did Finn
wolfhard say Wow
did she say so what did Finn wolfhard
say I'm not even gonna say it just like
to a dog at women he is a twin yes we
know his know a snap Canadian they do
yes well I don't really know not really
like my parents were born there but I'm
not oh hey there's no Tom Holland said
these boards were like okay is no shop
going on 14 going on tour where we going
Finn we're going to Delaware yeah make
sure to be there boy yeah no that's it
it's Noah snap perfect oh yeah look at
his little face I don't know about that
nobody's perfect
pobody's nerfect ya know cuz it's not
perfect they spelled is that the chairs
right there kind of
okay there's no ash snap speak French
yes you do
isn't know we should have speak French
this person know what does yeah I mean
maybe it's a French person that kiss
accomplished yes oui oui oui is
straightest Oh straight to things kids I
think we should do is stranger things
many many questions can be about that
all right is stranger things good you
have to find out first yeah I think so
yes stranger things scary yes actually
know if that's good no not that I think
it's more scary than anybody if you
don't make you watch it then it's
terrifying is stranger things the last
season
Oh three let's just go is stranger
things based on a true story
oh is it oh it is I don't know is really
Bobby Brown say in a British accent
buddy Roy is me brown room oh yes she is
and she sang on stage with them live
thank you know Adam I know I'm a true
man Amelia but Rick isn't lifting no I'm
not there's Millie Bobby Brown making
music I always make music is Millie
Bobby Brown finish I am NOT Spanish but
I was born in Spain
I'm fully British but a little Spanish
don't they see I was gonna say we could
use move on right next month does Finn
wolfhard play for it play for yes boy
that's been over before night now when I
have played for tonight before I've
never tried human for night yes does
Finn wolf part of it
oh no I'm looking to get a tattoo on my
face when I come back as Mike wheeler
I'm gonna be a new merged person okay
a real answer I am gonna get a touch of
my brother's name does does the wolf
hard love me love me oh you can so see
like a ten year old time I'm sure you do
Finn I'm sure I'm sure I do does fit a
wolf hard like I am from that Harry
Potter
and I just completely did a marathon
involve the movies and they were all
great recently that's been dismal hard
seeing a take on me I am in a Weezer
video and I sing a cover of take on me I
don't have to imagine it no ash snap
well just wall it sumus no yeah who
is no no I mean uh me hello nice to meet
you des Noah I keep going please
who is Noah snap it stranger things
oh I'm will Byers and next is no snaps
best friend
uh you guys million Finn because I was
just saying that but I like to think
it's true you know it I am is that right
yeah I do yeah
who is Noah shap celebrity crush
I have a couple I like zendaya she was
just here actually and now I'm standing
in her presence yeah and I love okay up
okay let's move on I do just most people
Google with no eyes with one hand that's
what I think
well if anyone googled those questions
where are your ants I mean I know I do
we are your answers so thank you don't
watch it without your wire it's a
complete interview jinx Oh